Selena Gomez spending some quality time
with her fam I love it the singer shared
some snaps while she enjoyed a boat day
with her stepdad Brian and younger
sister Gracie check her out all smiles
with her little sis I'm in a really
happy place it's been good sells quality
time with her family comes amid rumored
online drama over the last couple weeks
with Haley Bieber who's currently
married to Justin Bieber who Selena
dated on and off for years I would love
to have the opportunity to sit down with
every single person who has ever said
anything mean to me because
would be helping
me one instance a resurfaced video
showing Haley gagging At The Mention Of
Selena's bestie Taylor Swift full of the
meanest lyrics about a celebrity since
Taylor Swift's last album
but Selena was quick to come to her
BFF's defense writing so sorry my best
friend is and continues to be one of the
best in the game I'm very honest though
in general Haley and Kylie Jenner were
also accused of making fun of Selena's
eyebrows on Instagram I accidentally
laminated my brows too much after she
posted this Tick Tock Kylie shared some
pics of her and Haley's brows leading to
speculation of mocking Selena but the
rumored beef was squashed when Kylie
told fans this is reaching no shade
towards Selena ever and I didn't see her
eyebrow posts deep down like I would
love my true fans to know like all my
personal stuff Selena then cleared the
air writing agreed Kylie Jenner it's all
unnecessary I'm a fan of Kylie I was
okay with dealing with it in the wake of
all the drama Selena announced a social
media break I'm gonna be taking a second
from social media because
it's this is a little silly
and I'm 30. I'm too old for this so
but I love you guys so much
and I will see you guys
um sooner and later I just I'm gonna
just take a break from everything I'm
very lucky that I have a platform I have
but on social media it's as much as it's
a blessing and it's fun it it can really
tear people down and I always hope that
the people I'm involved with or support
me can just kind of spread love within
that looks like a little time off did
just the thing to get her back on track
I'm very happy I'm so blessed I'm the
best friends the best fans in the whole
world and I just couldn't be happier I
don't know I come I'm at that age where
I feel like that's what matters is
making sure I'm healthy and people are
happy that I love
[Music]